ce mois-ci dors bien vivre nous vous
présentons le nouveau visage de la
communauté d'agglomération puisque les
48 délégués communautaires ont été élus
en mars 2014 en même temps que les
conseils municipaux des 7 communes de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines c'est la
première fois que c'est délégués sont
élus au suffrage universel et la
première fois également que le nombre de
conseillers par commune dépend de leur
taille nouveau visage nouvelle majorité
nouveau délégués nous vous président
nouvelle orientations et grands projets
c'est tout de suite dans bien vivre
le 26 avril dernier avait lieu le
Conseil d'installation de la nouvelle
mandature de la communauté
d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines cette occasion
Michel Laugier maire de Montigny a été
élu nouveau président de la casqui alors
déjà le changement de majorité c'est le
résultat des derniers élections
municipales et élections communautaire
qui donne aujourd'hui donc cette
majorité à droite pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de 50 ans de vie
ensuite et bien c'est aussi le résultat
de beaucoup de travail puisque je suis
investi sur le territoire depuis bien
longtemps à différents titres et c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui je ressens ça comme
une certaine fierté et beaucoup
d'honneur
et à côté d'agglomération c'est
l'histoire importante sur les
territoires Yvelines
nous avons grandi avec différentes
structures la vie nouvelle le scan le
SAN aujourd'hui la communauté
d'agglomération de 50 ans d'Evelyne le
deuxième pôle et économique de l'Ouest
parisienne après la défense donc déjà
c'est l'importance de l'attache qui
m'attend la deuxième chose aussi c'est
que je suis pas quand même dans un
territoire inconnu puisque étant mère de
Montigny depuis 2004 je travaille
régulièrement avec la qualité d'Aglou et
ses services et puis depuis quelques
années aussi j'étais vice-président de
l'agglomération en charge des transports
et circulation une nouvelle majorité
donc une nouvelle équipe un nouveau
président est des priorités la première
mission est celle de mon équipe c'est de
faire un état des lieux de cette
communauté de l'agglomération dont
différents secteurs
populations
aux côtés de Michel logis 12 vices
présidents et trois conseillers
communautaires composent le bureau de la
communauté d'agglomération si bien que
51 soit déjà un bon modèle de bonne
entente et que mon entreprise un
facilitateur
dans ce cadre là moi je m'occuperai de
la délégation du développement
économique et des Finances donc pour
effectivement voir être encore plus
facilitateur
l'enjeu des de nos administrés c'est
l'emploi c'est clair c'est également le
niveau de vie comme on dit souvent un
champ public c'est pas brancher sur
Lourdes c'est branché sur l'activité
économique donc il faut bien sûr
remettre l'activité économique au centre
de toute politique aujourd'hui
c'est quand même une réussite 50 info
faut être faut le dire mais on peut on
peut bien sûr mettre beaucoup de
mécanismes pour améliorer la confiance
en toutes les acteurs trouver plus de
financement faciliter la R&D et puis
obtenir peut-être dans un cadre national
des expérimentations pour pour donner
encore plus envie aux entreprises de
donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes voilà
quelques grands projets et avec ce grand
laboratoire du futur jusque jusqu'à
Paris Messi vous avez entendu parler
avec 50 ans bien sûr au cœur de ce
dispositif
je suis d'accord très contente que
Monsieur logier méconfié l'aménagement
du territoire comme délégation
ça va permettre d'avoir une vision
globale du territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines y compris
j'irai de ces transports de sa
circulation comme sur une commune je
crois que la concertation sera une part
très importante de cet aménagement du
territoire je crois que les élus doivent
se nourrir de ce que pensent les
habitants de nos 7 communes surtout
lorsqu'on sait qu'on va aussi s'agrandir
probablement dans les deux heures qui
viennent donc ce qu'on va faire en
termes d'aménagement aujourd'hui il me
semble vraiment capital pour l'avenir de
la Grande Communauté d'Agglomération de
demain
la vice-président on se retrouve
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est travaux
bâtiments voirie patrimoine
délégation que j'ai déjà exercé depuis
deux ans à la suite du décès de Laurent
de biche et je l'amènerai dans la même
façon de travailler c'est à dire
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
les différentes communes et l'intérêt
général de la casquette maintenant à
nous de nous mettre au travail pour le
bien des 50 noirs
qui est important c'est de rassurer
rassurer d'une part les collaborateurs
de la communauté d'agglo qui sont
aujourd'hui des personnes qui
travaillent depuis pas mal d'années et
qui travaillent bien la deuxième chose
c'est rassuré aussi les chats
d'entreprise ils ont besoin aussi de
savoir comment va se dérouler l'avenir
de 50 ans des villes c'est aussi
important que les associations qui
bénéficient de l'aide de la communauté
d'agglomération soit rassurée les
investisseurs les investisseurs qui se
pressent au corps pour venir travailler
avec nous sur les territoires de 50 ans
divine et bien qu'il soit rassurés ils
seront accueillis et toujours mieux
accueilli afin que ils participent
largement au développement nouveau de 50
ans d'Évelyne pour mémoire la communauté
d'agglomération fonctionne avec
plusieurs instances le bureau et la bord
avec le président la politique de la
communauté d'agglomération étudie les
grands et prépare les propositions qui
seront étudiées par le Conseil de la
Communauté d'Agglo il travaille en lien
avec les commissions qui ont été
réduites de 17 à 4 pour gagner en
efficacité solidarité et qualité de vie
aménagement et travaux développement
économique et budget composé chacune de
13 membres du conseil communautaire
elles sont chargées d'étudier les
dossiers de l'agglomération qui les
concerne et de donner leur avis avant
leur passage au bureau un conseil
d'agglomération autre instance de la
case qui crée lors de la précédente
mandature et qui a été conservé le
conseil des maires composé des 7 mers de
l'agglomération se réunit régulièrement
pour examiner des dossiers particuliers
concernant l'ensemble des communes en
vue d'arriver à un consensus notamment
en matière de finances et d'urbanisme
l'avenir de la communauté
d'agglomération d'une part il y a un
navire proche et l'avenir proche c'est
celui que nous dicte la loi la loi
demande d'être au premier janvier 2016
dans une interconnalité qui accueillera
plus de 200 000 habitants le grand 50
pour moi c'est de récupérer les communes
de plaisir les clés Villepreux Maurepas
Coignières ainsi que les communes qui
font qui aujourd'hui
sont dans la communauté de communes de
la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse merci de la
deuxième façon de voir les choses c'est
effectivement de travailler avec les
autres communautés de l'agglomération
qui existent sur le plateau de Saclay a
commencé par Versailles rond-park aussi
mais aussi avec la CAPS parce que ça me
paraît important que tous ces
territoires se rapprochent afin de
pouvoir envisager un avenir qui sera
fait de coopération
Boxing Club de La Verrière a été sacré
championne de France de boxe éducative
en catégorie moins de 76 kg le 12 avril
lors des championnats nationaux qui se
sont déroulés à la Pommeraye une boxeuse
qui est fait tuer sa première saison de
boxe éducatif depuis plusieurs années la
casquille et les étudiants de l'Institut
supérieur de l'environnement réalise des
interventions communes de nettoyage sur
différents secteurs du territoire cette
année c'est la colline d'Élancourt qui a
été choisie pour plus d'efficacité vous
êtes conviés à les rejoindre le vendredi
23 mai le 13h à 17h 1500 c'est le nombre
d'associations actives réparties sur les
sept communes de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines la distribution sectorielle est
équilibrée avec toutefois une
prépondérance du secteur culturel qui
représente 21% de l'ensemble des
associations
la casquille organise une nouvelle vente
aux enchères du 12 au 26 mai elle
portera notamment sur du matériel
informatique le recyclé du mobilier de
bureau et sur des véhicules utilitaires
un dossier que vous pouvez retrouver
dans le petit Quentin ainsi qu'un
article sur Yaya Bianca auteur de un
petit baobab pour vivre ensemble et tout
le programme de la Nuit des musées à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à bientôt